[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
Oh God hey pasa man he's just sorry just
you in that chair
I think God would have made a damn fine
president you would have brought a real
dignity to the office you're welcome
America
welcome to Zombieland
life is about more than just survival we
were a family dysfunctional sure but
what family isn't very hurtful what
would you like little girl I really like
for you to stop calling me little girl
but you know what I would like I don't
give a [ __ ] what you it felt so good to
be on the move again oh my god I'm so
sorry hi I'm Columbus nothing this is
telling us II hate poplar this your dad
whoopsie I forgot this he thought wrong
oh so she knows the rules I told her
just a few of him
7300 and are there more you're cute I
like it mister is caught she picked up
the boy he's from Berkeley Berkeley you
have weed Dave do I look like the type
of person that would have weed I'm sorry
whoo-yah have nothing against hippie SOT
just won't beat the [ __ ] outta we're
gonna go get her we ride at dawn
[Music]
stop talking you first
[Music]
oh my apologies little Elvis is it me or
does he kind of remind you of I don't
like you at all
I think you double-parked one more
perpendicular parks hope we don't get a
ticket it's going on here
what hello everyone Vilas Nene yes looks
promising
he's so flexible yeah that's what's so
great about him he's very bendy hi Oh
whenever you're done with that
that's good hi-c mmm hi-c yeah the old
man is so tiny
can you see that it's his name you're so
tiny
no you're not hey you art no you're not
no you're not you're not my yours no
you're not
tiny big tiny she's adorable
how is that miss followed you
oh god those are t8 hundreds or at the
very least g7 hundreds it actually
wasn't he's a Yeti hundreds the first
model is great having two of you okay
time to nut up or shut up that sings
very 2009
[Laughter]
okay we got this whole I don't send a
boy to do a man's job we brought him
here we'll take care of it have Adam
hasta la vista baby Terminator 2 he's so
cool anybody else fine I was too
uniquely annoying uniquely no I loved
their chances and they'd Norview 52
don't be afraid to ask for help time to
nut up or shut up
need a new line let's kick some dicks
just because it rhymes doesn't make it a
great catchphrase
it's her prob I don't know I like it
when it runs
[Applause]
hands-down greatest I ever saw well
maybe not the greatest he was capable of
things you would literally not believe
was he like a big deal or something the
great is not be hunter of all time the
GZ hOAT the Gaza Haute
he's Tallahassee
well I first met Tallahassee and
Tallahassee playing ball way back away
in college you sure like an online
course can you play in an online course
is that like a computer game version or
something didn't you get hit a lot like
in the head I'm except that would kind
of explain something I did play a little
ball back in my day I had this move
called the Tallahassee 2 step step one
hit whatever's in front of you step 2
repeat he truly seemed to enjoy every
tackle I mean nobody else took that much
joy in hitting people and he hit like a
minivan no it's a minivan I mean once
the zombies took over sports just went
away
zombie hunting that was the only sport
left those were dark days a lot of ball
players did really well in the early
years after the outbreak but nobody did
it like Tallahassee you know I just came
natural to me must be in my blood he was
the biggest star in the only sport left
in the whole world SportsCenter top 10
every night until everyone at ESPN
turned into a zombie he does have a
beautiful swing mood swings his tackling
form textbook I don't know why he always
tackles textbooks but I guess he had
trouble in school could you describe a
relationship with Tallahassee with a
facial expression
he was a legend legend is strong that
will go right to his head the game has
been very good to me
I've been blessed to get to do what I
love because think about the sport of
zombie hunting is there's no final
buzzer you play until you can't some
folks think you know maybe Tallahassee
can't anymore
[Music]
the great ones rise to the occasion when
the moment comes when it's crunch time
Tallahassee is still demand I want taken
the shot honestly it's kind of on the
downslope it's a very steep down slope
like a like a cliff they say he's not
the same he's lost a step
great athletes they just can't quit the
game even when their bodies tell them
it's time his cat-like reflexes but dead
cat you know I hit his knee and a week
later he kicked me do I believe that
Tallahassee can get up off the mat one
more time
I certainly pretend to when he's around
been told I'm too slow too old too
unfocused what was the question again
athletes don't always get to decide when
they're done I think the game decides
for you or so written for me
I sleep in here as best I can because
it's soundproof and so people can't hear
me shrieking at the top of my lungs
crying myself to sleep waiting for the
zombies and the sweet release of death
for me I mean the upside was you know my
first love is golf and golf and zombie
hunting kind of go hand in hand we're
gonna call this one big swing get it
thank God for tape I will wreck Assam be
with this Golf Club this right here
lint roller crap it it myself with some
tape and candlestick thank yourself huh
I'm just trying my best man I mean I
don't know how you do a wheelchair is
anything on I what is this this is
Sports Center I'm Scott Van Pelt okay
describe a perfect day in Zombieland
[Music]
am I getting good at this I love being
back with everyone it just kind of feels
like getting to hang out with my buddies
again
it was crazy when we came back because
woody and Jessie both didn't know who I
was I think we figured out what was
working well in the first one and we
capitalized on it for this one
start talking you first tell her she
Nevada you know you're coming into a
family experience and so I feel really
lucky that I was able to tap into that
[Applause]
this is kind of remind you of hello
everyone
Lyle is Nina they said didn't you know
you're a poor man's jesse eisenberg I
said why hi I'm Columbus know why she's
still alive because zombies eat brains
and she got in a beam of light in a
world of darkness is the non-judgmental
way of describing her it felt like it
would be a fantastic standalone movie
even if it wasn't associated with the
first time for sure that sings very 2009
didn't see that coming right the thing
that you're gonna like is just how we
get along or how we don't get along guys
they're much more afraid of us than we
are of them you'll be the first to die
but I like your enthusiasm you might die
thank you for your sacrifice
[Music]